how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu now last
week at disney's investor day marvel
shocked us all marvel studios president
kevin feige revealed a ton
of new projects coming to the mcu and
revealed part of phase 5.
now we were expecting like a one
division trailer and possibly a first
look at the falcon and the winter
soldier instead
we got all of that plus 30 minutes of
new marvel
content now marvel said that all of
these projects were going to be coming
out over the next few years of course in
phase four and phase five but that's all
they really gave us for release dates
until now after the investor day disney
has now released the document
the 2020 investor day programming fact
sheet
and in this document they line up the
order of release dates for all of their
upcoming marvel projects
so i'll go over the release date order
so you know exactly when all of these
shows and movies are going to come out
and i'll also read the little synopsis
that marvel and disney has put for each
project
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a tony stark
quantum suit funko pop provided by
heroeshideout.com
so this sheet breaks it off into disney
plus shows and feature films and will
start just as it starts with the disney
plush shows
and of course as we know it starts with
wanda vision and it says one of vision
launching on disney plus
on january 15th of 2021 marvel studios
is first
series that continues to expand the mcu
wanda maximoff and vision are two
super powered beings our living idolized
suburban lives but begin to suspect
everything is not as it seems then we
have the falcon and the winter soldier
and they say kicking off on disney plus
march 19th
2021 a new series starring anthony
mackie as sam wilson aka the falcon and
sebastian stand as bucky barnes aka the
winter soldier
the pair who came together in the final
moments of avengers in-game
team up on a global adventure that tests
their abilities and
their patience then we have loki set to
debut on disney plus
in may in 2021 featuring the god of
mischief as he steps out of his
brother's shadow in a new series that
takes place after the events of avengers
end game
we then have what if and it says what if
flips a script on the mcu
reimagining famous events from the films
in unexpected ways
coming to disney plus in summer 2021
marvel studios first animated series
focuses on different heroes from the mcu
featuring a voice cast that includes a
host of stars who reprise their roles we
then have miss marvel and it actually
gives us
quite a bit of information it says ms
marvel launching on disney plus
in late 2021 is a new series that
introduces kamala khan
a 16 year old pakistani american growing
up in jersey city
a great student an avid gamer and a
voracious fan
fiction scribe she has a special
affinity for superheroes particularly
captain marvel but kamala struggles to
fit in at home
and at school that is until she gets
super powers like the heroes she's
always looked up to
life is easier with super powers right
aman valani stars as kamala khan
aka miss marvel then we have the hawkeye
series which debuts on disney plus in
late 2021
jeremy renner is hawkeye who teams up
with another well-known archer from the
marvel comics
kate bishop played by haley steinfeld
then comes
she-hulk a new comedy series coming to
disney plus stars tatiana maslany as she
hulk slash jennifer walters a lawyer who
specializes in superhuman-oriented
legal cases she-hulk will welcome a host
of marvel characters to the series
including the hulk played by mark
ruffalo
and the abomination played by tim roth
up next is moon knight a new series
created for disney plus
directed by muhammad diab the action
adventure features a complex vigilante
who suffers from dissociative identity
disorder
the multiple identities who live inside
him are distinct
characters who appear against a backdrop
of egyptian iconography
then we have secret invasion a newly
announced series heading to disney plus
that stars samuel l jackson as nick fury
and ben mendelson as the scroll talos
characters who first met in captain
marvel the crossover comic event series
showcases a faction of shape-shifting
scrolls who have been infiltrating earth
for years
next is iron heart the second of the
newly announced series coming to disney
plus stars dominique
thorne as riri williams a genius
inventor who creates the most advanced
suit of armor
since iron man then we have armor wars
based on the classic marvel comic series
comes to disney plus starring don
chadell
as james rhodes aka war machine who must
face what happens when tony stark's tech
falls into the wrong hands now for moon
knight secret invasion
iron heart and armor wars they didn't
give us a release date however
they put the series between hawkeye and
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
hawkeye comes out in late 2021 and the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
will come out in late 2022
so these series moon knight secret
invasion iron heart and armor wars
should come out between
2021 and 2022 and for guardians of the
galaxy holiday special it says that it's
slated for disney plus during the 2022
holiday season
written and directed by guardians of the
galaxy veteran james gunn
and then last but not least we have i am
groot featuring everyone's favorite baby
tree in a series of original shorts
coming to disney plus and they do not
give a release date for this
but now we move into films and we start
with black widow and we pretty much know
a lot about this at this point but they
have confirmed the may 7th
2021 release date then we have shang chi
and the legend of the ten rings shang
chin the legend of the ten rings opening
july
9th 2021 stars sima liu as
shang chi who must confront the past he
thought he left behind when he is drawn
into the web of a mysterious
10 rings organization coming after shang
chi
is the eternals opening november 5th of
2021
it features the mcu's newest ensemble of
superheroes and an epic story that spans
thousands of years directed by chloe zao
eternals features a group of immortal
heroes
forced out of the shadows to reunite
against mankind's oldest enemy the
deviants
then we have doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness debuting
march 25th of 2022 and it does confirm
that elizabeth olsen will be in the
movie benedict
wong is returning along with rachel
mcadams and chiwatel aegea4
and zachatel gomez joins them playing
america chavez
then we have thor love and thunder
opening on may 6th
of 2022 and they have confirmed that
christian bale is going to be
gore the god butcher and then to our
surprise they announced a release date
for black panther 2.
coming july 8th of 2022 the movie is
being written and directed by ryan
coogler
and marvel has officially stated in
order to honor chadwick boseman they
will not recast the character
next is blade and although they don't
list a release date they do put it
between black panther 2
and captain marvel 2. black panther 2
comes out in july 8th of 2022
and captain marvel comes out november
11th of 2022
so we can put it in between there most
likely an august 2022 release date and
as i mentioned captain marvel 2 will
come out on november 11th of 2022
then we have ant-man and the wasp
quantum
mania there is no release date for this
but it comes after captain marvel 2
which is november 11 2022 but before
guardians of the galaxy in 2023 so
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania will
most likely come out early in 2023
there is no synopsis but they do confirm
that jonathan majors is going to be
kang the conqueror in the movie and then
we have guardians of the galaxy vol 3
slated for
2023 with director james gunn back of
the helm
and to finish it off we have the
fantastic four stated
last which means it's going to be coming
after guardians of the galaxy 3 which is
2023
so fantastic four is looking at a late
2023 release date or
an early 2024. and there you have it
marvel has announced the releases for
all of their upcoming
mini projects let me know which one you
are looking forward to the most
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all things relating to the mcu for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof